tu es aux prochaines vidéos c'est là dit
me repose je vous remercie monsieur le
président sécurité le secrétaire général
de la ligue
chaque collègue mesdames et messieurs
vous cette année la communauté mondiale
de grandes anniversaire historique
ce militant le deuxième anniversaire de
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
habib signé la fondation des nations
unies l'importance de ces deux
événements historiques reçu début août
sur le code ou en 1945 le régime nazi a
ici été vaincu nous avons vaincu la
haine tandis que c'est l'esprit cas pour
allier et la compréhension du prix qui a
été payé pour notre victoire commune
nous a permis de construire le monde
contemporain basé sur la charia des
nations unies y reste
dès aujourd'hui la grande source du
droit international
l'unige et je suis convaincu que cet
anniversaire d'aujourd'hui nos deux
oreilles des grands principes de la
charte onusienne
on est international qu'est ce qu'un
mini ses fondateurs les nations unies
tubes que l'on formule douce très
nettement réduite et c'est l'égalité
j'ai payé ce brun c'est la non ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures le droit
de disposer d'un homme
l'abandon de la force et la solution
politique les conflits en remontant
s'est désuni et coller on peut dire que
malgré toutes les difficultés de la
guerre froide malgré les troubles
géopolitiques
malgré toutes les nuances de la
politique internationale le nude rempli
sa mission
sauvegarder la paix contribuer au
développement durable du continent des
peuples et aider à surmonter des
conflits locaux
ce potentiel est colossal et
l'expérience des nations unies est très
demandé et c'est une base pour avancer
comme tout organisme international bien
une structure régionale
le nu ne doit pas être un organisme figé
mais refléter la dynamique du 21e siècle
et être adapté aux réalités du monde
moderne
effectivement notre monde devient de
plus en plus compliqué multipolaire et
du changement qui se souviennent bien
sûr on a un impact sur la le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies sur le débat
autour de la réforme du conseil de
sécurité
notre logique est que le conseil de
sécurité soit à même de prendre en
compte les intérêts de tous les pays
pour qu'ils se fonde sur la conciliation
des états mais en même temps comme dans
le passé
il serait un outil clé de la gouvernance
mondiale avec ce droit de veto des
membres permanents je parle de 5 pi
vainqueur dans la seconde guerre
mondiale qui réflète l'équilibré
militaire et politique d'aujourd'hui
c'est un outil nécessaire et unique qui
ne permet pas d'actions unilatérales et
la confrontation militaire entre les
superpuissances
il permet de rechercher un compromis et
abandonner les solutions qui ne sont pas
acceptables et être toujours dans le
cadre du droit international et non pas
dans une zone vague
d'arbitraire et comme le montre la
politique diplomatique cet outil
fonctionne
contrairement aux l'expérience de la
ligue des nations avec des maintes
discussions sans action efficace sans le
droit des états qui sont en péril d'être
protégés oubliées les leçons de
l'histoire c'est être sans
responsabilité tandis que être en avoir
des tentatives de d'interpréter les le
cours de la seconde guerre mondiale et
réviser les décisions des alliés et du
procès de nuremberg
c'est le crime contre la mémoire il nous
est cher et le coup dur sur les
fondamentaux de l'après guerre c'est
très dangereux quand la stabilité
internationale est empreint de grandes
épreuves
je parle du contrôle des armements je
parle des conflits locaux
je parle du terrorisme de la criminalité
et du trafic des drogues
nous sommes en face des défis tout
nouvel essai la pandémie du collier de
19 qui a affecté des millions de gens et
qui a emporté des centaines de milles de
vie la fermeture des frontières et
beaucoup de problèmes lourds pour toute
la population ce sont les problèmes de
nos jours c'est très lourd pour
et j'enrage et ils sont obligés de
rester chez eux et ne pas voir leurs
enfants revient leurs petits enfants
les experts ont encore à apprécier
toutes les échelles de ce choc
économique et ses conséquences et bien
sûr dès aujourd'hui il est évident que
nous serons obligés de reconstituer
l'économie mondiale pendant très
longtemps en n'utilisant pas forcément
des méthodes qui sont éprouvés nous
aurons besoin des méthodes nouvelles
mais faut travailler ensemble et c'est
une mission très importante pour les
nations unies et pour le groupe de vins
et bien sûr pour tous les autres
organismes internationaux et des
structures internationales qui suite à
cette pandémie traverse une période très
difficile et nécessite de nouveaux
horizons et des missions de
développement
cette intégration de l'intégration et
sert de base de l'initiative russe du
partenariat euro asiatique avec la
participation des pays européens et
asiatiques c'est une approche
pragmatique et qui devient de plus en
plus d'actualité et je porte votre
attention sur la position proposition
russe de création des couloirs verts qui
ne connaissent pas des barrières pour
acheminer des médicaments des vivres des
moyens de protection qui sont
nécessaires pour la lutte contre la
pandémie en général c'était épuration du
commerce international des barrières des
sanctions illégitime
tout cela pourrait être
une bonne base pour le rétablissement et
économique pour la lutte contre le
chômage
les experts estiment que la réduction
totale ou bien partielle de l'emploi est
égal à l'abandon la perte de 400 mille
emplois ce chômage nous oblige de faire
tout notre possible pour que les gens
reviennent vers leur travail qui sont en
froid de la pauvreté sans perspective
dans leur vie c'est un problème social
global c'est pourquoi il faut freiner la
route pour le commerce pour la
conférence concurrence loyale et non pas
brider la concurrence la pandémie a posé
un grand nombre de sujets technologiques
humanitaire
par exemple le numérique nous a permis
de reconstruire le système de formation
le système de santé et cette
intelligence artificielle à aider les
médecins à faire des diagnostics pour
rechercher des schémas de traitement
mais bien sûr comme toute innovation le
numérique et doit être gérables et comme
tout armement et il peut être dans les
mains des radicaux bien des extrémistes
non seulement dans des régions de
conflits mais dans d'autres pays
développés
c'est pourquoi les questions de
cybersécurité et l'emploi des nouvelles
technologies nécessitent une discussion
sur la plateforme onusienne il faut
exprimer nos craintes puisque à cette
époque il faut être protégé par exemple
la vie privée doit être protégé la
sécurité doit être protégé il faut
apprendre à utiliser les nouvelles
technologies pour le bien de l'humanité
avoir une haie équilibre entre le
développement de l'un
les gens sont artificielles et les
limites de ce développement il faut et
rechercher la gestion des menaces
éventuelles non seulement du point de
vue militaire et technologique mais
aussi du point de vue des traditions du
droit du moral et à l'époque des
pandémies et les médecins des bénévoles
ont fait preuve de l'entr'aide du
soutien mutuel cette solidarité n'a pas
de frontières de nombreux pays honte d
les uns les autres aux autres mais ont
fait preuve également d'un difficile du
de l'humanisme de cette bonté si vous
voulez à l'échelle inter gouvernementale
en terre entre les états je crois que
l'autorité des nations unies voudrait
nous aider à augmenter l'importance de
ce volet humanitaire par exemple les
échanges entre des jeunes les liens
culturels les programmes d'enseignement
de formation les programmes d'échangé
dans le domaine du sport des sciences de
l'environnement et de la santé
concernant la santé justement ici comme
dans l'économie il faut lever les
barrières et notre pays a participé de
façon active dans des efforts
internationaux de ne te contre kevin 19
à la base multilatérale mais aussi du
latéral non le faisons compte tenu du
rôle central et coordonnée de
l'organisation mondiale de santé qui
fait partie de la structure des nations
unies je craque
il faut renforcer le potentiel de nos
messes et la russie va participer de
façon active à ce processus
notre expérience scientifique
industrielle et l'expérience clinique
des médecins russes ont permis à mettre
au point les tests nous permettent de
lutter contre la corrida est ensuite
enregistrée le premier vaccin au monde
je répète nous sommes ouverts et nous
sommes ouvertes pour la coopération et
notre initiative
ces deux organisé une conférence en
ligne de haut niveau avec la
participation des chefs d'état qui sont
intéressés par la coopération
internationale dans le domaine de la
création du vaccin vaccin et coopère
avec tout état et structures
internationales par exemple les
livraisons du vaccin
le russe qui a fait preuve la fiabilité
la sécurité et l'efficacité
la russie est persuadé qu'il faut
utiliser tous les moyens de l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour dans l'avenir très
proche
garantir l'accès aux vaccins pour tous
les citoyens de tous les pays
puisque chacun pourrait être confronté à
ce vaccin
même le personnel des nations unies
le siège des nations unies et les
structures régionales
la russie est prête à soutenir et aider
les nations unies nous proposons le
vaccin russe gratuitement aux personnels
volontaires des nations unies puisque
nous avons déjà reçu les demandes de la
part des collègues des nations unies et
bien sûr nous acceptons ces demandes
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore d'importants
dans l'agenda international
il est important de d'être soucieux de
la question de l'environnement de
l'évolution du climat et tout ceci est
toujours d'actualité et toutes les
conventions multilatérales
et protocoles qui ont été signés le
montre et nous appelons tous les états à
traiter cette question de façon
responsable et de chercher à atteindre
tous les objectifs fixés à l'accord de
paris vous chers collègues
encore une fois je voudrais encore vous
dire que la russie fera tous ses efforts
pour participer à une règle un règlement
pacifique de tout les problèmes qui se
posent aujourd'hui sur les plans
stratégique malgré tout les divergences
les incompréhensions et même parfois la
méfiance
nous allons insister sur la nécessité d'
à des initiatives de discussions et
notamment en matière de contrôle des
armements et de mettre en place un
système de traité sur l'interdiction des
armes chimiques biologiques et toxiques
la première question qui se pose
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est la
poursuite de l'accord entre la russie et
les etats unis sur les armes aux
offensives qui expirent en 2021 et nous
menons des discussions avec nos
partenaires américains et nous insistons
sur la nécessité de limiter la portée
des missiles concerné et dé l'année
dernière j'insiste là dessus nous avons
proposé un moratoire sur l'installation
de tels missiles en europe et dans
d'autres zones
tant que les états unis et ne serons pas
signataires de tel et pour l'instant
nous n'entendons pas de réponse de la
part des états unis à notre proposition
et je suis convaincu que les discussions
sur toutes ces questions constitueraient
une bonne base pour un dialogue
approfondi et complet sur qui est
capable d'assurer la stabilité
stratégique
encore une fois nous insistons sur la
nécessité
le conclure des accord complet qu'il
puisse permettre de d'édifier cette
architecture de l'instabilité de la paix
et qui correspondent non seulement aux
préoccupations aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi à celle de l'avenir qui
peuvent revêtir un caractère aussi
technologique
il faut que ce soit d accord
contraignant qui concerne aussi toutes
les puissances spatiales avec
l'interdiction de placement d'armement
dans l'espace et aussi en matière de
protection des objets spatiaux et tous
les problèmes qui se meuvent qui peuvent
se poser poser aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu se réfère à toutes ces
valeurs qui nous unissent notre mémoire
collective sur l'esprit d'alliance sur
les leçons du passé sur la possibilité
de remporter des victoires ensemble tout
cela concerne l'ensemble des peuples du
monde et tout cela est plus important
que toutes les divergences et que nous
puce pouvons connaître aujourd'hui
or dans l'édifice dans la situation
difficile que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui nous devons faire preuve de
sagesse de bonne volonté et tout cela
impose aux puissances membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu de bien
prendre conscience de leur
responsabilité dans cette manche cette
matière du maintien de la paix et en
étant consciente de 7 ans consciente de
cette responsabilité
la russie a proposé donc une réunion des
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité pour trouver des solutions
efficaces et
pour résoudre ces défis qui se posent
aujourd'hui et nous espérons mener une
telle réunion des visions dans un
objectif dans un avenir suffisamment
proche dès que les conditions sanitaires
ne permettront dans le monde
interdépendant que nous connaissons dans
cette dans ce tourbillon d'événements
internationaux
nous devons travailler de concert
proposé des solutions en commun et ce
n'est qu'un psy que nous serons capables
de remplir les grandes missions de notre
organisation internationale et d'assurer
l'avenir de nos des générations qui vont
nous suivre je souhaite à tous les
peuples de la terre paix et prospérité
je vous remercie pour votre attention